hello folks welcome to
rational science the only site on the
internet that does
physics
everybody else does descriptions
which means uh mathematics as i call it
mathematics they do equations
and move concepts around
so we have a difference in this channel
from everybody else on the planet
because we follow
a different scientific method here's a
summary just so you
come up to speed okay let's see if i can
put this up here
this is the standard scientific method
that we have uh today that's the one
they teach you in high school and in
college
you observe
you make a prediction you run some kind
of experiment
measure uh
you can make a prediction as well right
there
collect data for evidence describe with
an equation discover a novel behavior
and then you present the evidence to the
powers that be which are your buddies
you know your colleagues
they vote
uh
there's some kind of result they call
knowledge
and you repeat the process to confirm
the knowledge you know that everything
was done properly you check all the uh
[Music]
dot all the x's
dot all the i's and uh cross all the t's
so to speak
and then uh invent a new gadget that
proves the theory apparently you know
computers prove quantum they say okay
and uh and then you award a prize to
certify knowledge to you know you give
them a nobel prize and now the guy has
certified knowledge
uh we
throw all this in the trash can we say
oh that's a method of research and
persuasion none of it has anything at
all to do with science what does science
do
science we have to explain
a uh theory rationally to another human
being okay
it could be to yourself by the way you
could be talking in the mirror no
problem you want to
make sure you can explain it someone
else so you first explain it to yourself
first thing you do in physics as far as
physics is concerned
you present the objects what objects are
going to be moving in your movie in the
one where you
allegedly are going to explain some
phenomenon of nature you have to have
objects
without objects you cannot do physics
and that golden principle as i call it
no one has understood it or discovered
it in thousands of years
definitions you have to define your
terms and mathematicians don't like to
define their terms because they don't
want to be
uh
tied to a given definition because it
might be
destroyed
so
they either don't define or define
loosely or define a word in ten
different ways so they can use it in
different ways in other words they cover
all the bases now in science we have one
definition per word so we can follow the
presentation and then uh
you know you present the initial scene
could be the first few frames so that
you can present
the foundation of your theory what
you're going to try to explain
essentially and then you explain it
that's the theory
and so we have a different scientific
method than everybody else uh everybody
essentially
does
mathematics
and i'll tell you something the reason
we ended up with this
uh notion of
uh
the scientific method or science right
is because the mathematicians were in
charge throughout all these years
ever since plato at least you would say
but for sure
uh 400 years ago you know where the
so-called scientific revolution what
happened was they
the mathematicians took over
and the mathematicians are all religious
people they're all
people who move concepts around
okay and so that's very scary and so
what they've done is they created words
that have no place in science in terms
of religion i call them words such as
energy
and field
and
wave
those words
are not part of science they can't be
used as physical objects which is
exactly how the mathematicians use them
to provide a physical interpretation
to phenomena
and that's where
we draw the line we say physics you need
to use objects and so the first word you
need to define is the word object
if you cannot define the word object or
don't understand what the word object
means and all the implications it has
well you're not doing physics okay so
the first word you need to understand in
physics is the word object and that's
why our site is a little different than
everybody else's out there um and what i
do in these uh
lectures
is divide them in three parts first part
we do extinction
uh why do i do extinction i think it's a
branch of physics first of all okay
paleontology is a branch of physics
paleontology is the science that studies
death
okay
a paleontologist is a necrologist a
medical examiner he's got to tell us how
species in the past died
and the reason i've included in my
lectures is because the mathematicians
who rule the world of so-called science
um
they believe we're going to live forever
they all think we're going to get out of
this planet uh conquer maybe i don't
know mars first maybe venus uh and then
move on maybe to other planets in the
solar system eventually to another star
and eventually we conquer the whole
galaxy
and that's a little different than what
i think is going to happen i used to
believe that by the way so i'm guilty
but
i've changed my mind after reasoning i'm
saying we're not ever going to reach the
nearest star
i don't think we're ever going to
colonize
mars or any other planets we might
travel there physically you know might
send some astronauts a party of 5-10
people yeah we can do that probably okay
i don't even think we're going to be
able to do that
but
i think it's within our possibilities we
would be able to do something like that
given enough time okay
and um
so i don't think we're going to go
out of the solar system
and i don't think we have to wait for
the sun to explode before we die
it's gonna happen a lot sooner like in a
couple years maybe
and the reason i believe that i think
the global economy is going to collapse
when not if but when it does
then
we have nothing to trade
there will be no more trade what dies is
trade without trade
no one produces food
no one distributes food to the cities
and billions of people die in a matter
of weeks okay so that's the overall
theory so uh the first part of the
lecture is about
subjects related to extinction okay that
gives you a clue that something is wrong
today
terribly wrong
then the second part we do what uh
physics proper in this case uh we're
gonna be looking at transparency and
opacity today i'm going to cover a fifth
variable okay
and then i'm gonna
answer some questions and comments that
people made since last time
okay so let's get on with it let's go
along with uh extinction and i start
with a little uh
news headline that came out there
caught my eye
and it's uh this fella he's uh turned
into a woman he
he uh did a uh
he played a bruce jenner he turned into
a woman and he went in there and did
some kickboxing and beat up
a girl
okay and so a lot of people have
problems with this lots of people have
problems with this among them the girls
that get
they get beat up
because they say well you know you can
look at the guy and he looks like a man
i mean he's uh he's been a a man
you could say this uh for 30 plus years
and he decided to make a sex change
operation
recently i don't know
how recently it was
but the bottom line is he's already
built like a man now he's changed his
sex you know and he goes out there and
fights these
pure women you can say right
and people have problems with that they
say look you know
you're matching men against women here
okay
so that's
the argument out there and uh so
i i i'm gonna play devil's advocate here
okay
so what
why don't we make all sports unisex
is there a problem with that
boxing foot american football soccer uh
you naming heist hockey
wrestling weight lifting
javelin throw uh discus throw the whole
works
let's make it unisex
no differences
and you say well bill that's unfair
it's unfair because uh women are
are at a disadvantage
well in this day and age first of all
women are asking for their rights they
want to be equals
so that's my first argument again i'm
going to play a devil's advocate here
women want to be our equals right we're
all born equal we all have the same
rights we all
uh want wanna
uh you know
have no differences out there because uh
men have uh dominated women for so long
now women wanna be equal to men so okay
here's their chance i mean you know
let's get in the ring and fight right
now that's one argument the other
argument is um
you know uh women
there are many women that out there that
are professionals obviously
they can beat up a lot of men
okay
this is just a fact okay
and you say well yeah but you get the
top contender for
the women's championship against the
topkin center for the contender for the
men's championship of boxing or whatever
one of those rough sports you know and
men are gonna win
and my answer to you is
today
okay today
we might win or are likely to win how
about tomorrow
i mean given enough time let's assume
extinction doesn't happen we give it
another hundred years and we open the
floor for everybody
no more none of this sucks stuff okay
uh it's all unisex for all sports
will there be women that slowly come up
the ranks and match the best of men
okay and i'm gonna give you an example
of what i'm talking about okay
if i can get it here give me a second
here
and it goes like this
okay
uh
this is 100 meter dash in 1936.
okay
and what we see we see uh jesse owens
famous guy you know he won
the 100 meter dash and at the time his
record was 10.3
seconds which was the world record
guy who came in second another american
ralph metcalfe
and he came in just a bit tiny
bit behind him 10.4
well uh the record for women is held by
florence griffin
and she did it in 10.49
and she would have slaughtered uh mark
martinez
ozentarp uh
who came in third in in that race at
10.5 she would have been beat him by a
hundredth of a second and then after
that uh would come elaine thompson who
won it this year and she would have
beaten the crap out of the next uh three
guys
down there
so have women come up to speed over the
years and on top of that you know just
just in case you didn't notice uh we're
talking about two black girls beating
these white folks you know
[Laughter]
how embarrassing right
so uh given enough time can women outrun
men or
run just as fast
can they compete against men in strength
and in
stamina or whatever all those
maybe not in beauty
men in beauty contest could be you know
the way the world's going but i mean uh
we we have a situation here where women
have come up their eggs women have
matched a lot of the
records that men in the past uh held us
you know
as sacred
and women today now would have beaten
those men you know 1500 years ago
and so uh women are also improving on
their speeds and so on will there be a
time where women and men are
on the par
should we have even
male and female bathrooms
restrooms
public ones or even private ones i mean
for that matter right
uh is there any problem with that i mean
nudist beaches
the uh females and males at least get a
shower
you know before going into the pool they
all shower in the same place no problem
they still for whatever reason that i
cannot understand have uh
female bathrooms and
men's
uh bathrooms
and i don't know why they don't have a
single bathroom i mean you can have
individual stalls i can understand that
you know because even ben you know they
want to do their stuff in private no
problem why do we have female and male
bathrooms
you know can we all go to the same
bathroom after all you know do we need
to wear clothes
those were invented as far as i'm
concerned about 35 maybe to 40 000 years
ago which is when man entered europe do
we need clothes
i mean when it's a hot day
you know take it all off right
why not i mean if we don't need clothes
then maybe we don't need to worry about
having all these rules out there you
know as far as bathrooms and so on you
know i mean you dress up when it's cold
maybe in winter no problem and then you
take it off in summer
any problem with that
uh and let me give you a for instance uh
the uh
women especially in places like
afghanistan
you know they wear that veil over their
face they cover it all
and they feel nude if
they were to take that little veil off
they feel nude they feel that something
is wrong then they're not used to it
it's part of their culture part of their
brain now
okay so it's not only the men who have
forced them maybe to use that over time
could be
but now the women you know who are born
in that society
they're conditioned to use that veil and
you can't get it out of their face
because they believe in that that's how
what they are
so think about all this you know do we
need to have differences between males
and females
especially in sports
okay moving on here uh
more related to the subject here and the
reason i'm raising that is uh you know
given enough time maybe just maybe women
will catch up if we give them enough
time maybe it's too late maybe
extinction will happen before equality
happens and that applies also to racism
and so on you know i think
we're working in that direction will we
ever reach
that point where women are equal to men
politically
uh salary wise et cetera et cetera will
blacks be equal to men especially in
places like the united states you know
uh will there be total equality
and uh i don't know
we may not have enough time for all that
anyways mitch mcconnell a person from
the gop randall party he says that gop
will vote for the u.s to default on its
debt
they're going to be voting i think in
november is the cutoff date
and what are they going to vote for well
right now they want to raise the ceiling
to 27 trillion dollars
which is what
99.3 percent of gdp
debt
is right up there with gdp
do you think that's uh healthy
uh are we going to continue for the next
100 or 200 or 300 years
uh with uh gdp being
at or below the level of debt
and i'm picking on the united states but
almost every country is there okay
every country debt is climbing for all
governments reaching
that plateau where it meets
gdp
and so the question is
what do you think of that do you think
uh this is healthy this is normal this
is something we can handle no problem
or is this something new where dead is
just outrageously
out the door you know uh over the hill
so to speak uh under uh completely
uncontrolled
and
what every government does because
really every government does it every
time they come in they
go to congress and they say look we got
to vote a new limit
and so all they're doing is devaluing
the coin which is what's going to i
think take one of the
trends that's going to take to
uh the
uh
the worthlessness
of the dollar of the of money itself and
again the only empire that needs to
where it needs to happen is the united
states once it happens there we're all
done
okay so uh we're taking taking this to
the limit where at some point
money will have no value because what
you're receiving is debt
not
not
assets okay anyways that's food for
thought we're throwing it in there so
that all you economists who are experts
in economy uh uh can answer the question
okay here's a
another a bit of news i'm not going to
read all that i just want to mention
that
they've discovered okay apparently
anonymous the people with the uh
with the
faces and they found out who the
who's behind the proud boys found a
whole bunch of names
and the question for you is whether this
is uh this anonymous is that the
government
how about the proud boys are they the
government
okay uh
are we having here um some stuff that we
don't understand that we don't know that
uh
is used for
to to
as part of policy on the one hand and
also to
recruit people one side or the other or
gauge the population see which way they
lean
is this manipulation where uh
you know the politicians or whoever out
there maybe it's the illuminati the new
world order folk the the elites whatever
you want to call them are they uh are
they behind all these groups
and
do you think that for example the fbi
do you think the fbi infiltrates any
group that becomes important
okay
food for thought
okay let's move on
let's move on
uh
one fellow says will you elaborate on
why urbanization
leads to fewer children
why does urbanization destroy birth
traits
another fellow ass and he says is it
because uh farms need a ton of workers
and a third guy answers them says the
cause is feminist laws
he's a taliban okay
he visits us from kabul okay
and a
fourth guy here he comes in he says the
reason people don't have children's
culture
as soon as having children and family
will be glorified people will start
having children again in cities or not
okay
so uh those are some of the answers we
get out there uh my take i can only give
you my version of it okay here it is
uh
why don't we have children today
well the main reason is we went from the
country to the city women from the farms
to the offices that's what it's all
about we went from agriculture first to
manufacturing in the cities and then
from the cities we converted from
manufacturing
to services
okay that's what's happened that's the
transition that's happened since the
19th century and so these are the
variables that i throw at you okay for
you to ponder crowdedness is one you
know density dependent birth rates
that's number one okay
and uh you know it's uh when when you
get into a city
it's crowded
economy is uh very lean for most people
okay they're just barely making it to
the end of the month
and then you have the houses you know
they're no longer like in the farm you
have all these extensions out there
and you want to bequeath the land to
whom to your sons or daughters right
and none of that happens in the city in
the city there's nothing to bequeath
except debts
gdp
up to
same level as debt okay so uh
you know there's nothing to bequeath so
who what are you going to have a child
for you're not going to be quetta to him
to her or him right
you're in an apartment are you going to
have 10 kids
do you have enough money to maintain 10
kids even if the apartment is you know a
suite the palace hotel
suite you know
uh no and so these are some of the
reasons some of the problems economics
proletarians can barely make it to the
end of the month in a service economy
social security retirement you know in
the country a lot of people had kids and
those kids later on took care of mama
and papa okay
and today you know the state take care
of the children and the state takes care
of the mom and papa so the working
people don't have to worry about those
things
anymore okay
so
again you know no more so no
social security that's dependent on
children on your under on your kids okay
uh nothing to bequeath again culture
freedom from shackles i mean
the culture changes and couples when
wherever there are couples long-lasting
couples you know they want to travel
they want to do some stuff
and a kid just holds them down the kid's
an anchor okay so this is a problem as
well
no purpose for having them
you know in the old days they had a
purpose again sometimes the kids
inherited they also took care of mom and
papa that was their social security uh
there was a reason to have children
aside from the type of life you know
these people were out there uh
farming and what did they do for fun
there was no radio no tv
okay you figured it out okay
uh today we have other distractions
mainly games everybody's playing all
these games right and because of that
there's no time for sex
uh reproductive sex sex there's a lot
and most of it is self-serve
but uh
but what there isn't is uh
is time for sex for um for real sex for
reproductive sex the
purpose mother nature created sex for
okay uh family structure has changed
also you know
hunter gathers we had the clan everybody
did it with everybody it was a
free-for-all you know you could sleep
with your mother with your daughter
whatever happened there was group sex
okay
uh agricultural uh
era uh slavery a lot of slaveries okay
people were conquered in war thinking of
slaves to work the farms and inside the
houses right
and uh so it was a patriarchal society
where
the men of the house he had even power
of life and death not only of his over
the slaves but over his children and of
his wife
those were the good old days
today is almost the other way around
okay manufacturing we went to the
nuclear family you know mom and pop
no more extended family it was mom and
popping the kids
okay
and from there we went to services what
are services bachelors divorced
uh homosexuals
in other words
everybody lives alone it's a single life
so we went from many to the few
okay
uh is that going to continue forever now
for hundreds and hundreds of years
always singles and just casual sex here
and there for pleasure
you figure it out okay
so again you know what i try to show is
that uh we're at a
different culture a different economic
situation today
and so
i don't know you gotta think for
yourself if any of this has a bearing on
extinction
okay um
and anyways even if uh
uh
you know couples could reproduce we're
not reproducing and here you see the
trend okay i showed this a couple times
already but uh by mid-century 2015 we're
going to reach what is known as zpg
zero population growth
one person dies one person is born more
or less uh remains steady so there's no
uh
increment in the population the world
population
in fact it should decline even further
because we're becoming older and at some
point the older people start dying and
we're not producing the young
because the young are not
marrying or or having sex for the
purposes of reproduction reproductive
sex right
and so yeah i think it's gonna continue
all the way down okay and i think in
fact uh
mother nature is gonna save us the agony
of defeat
gonna save us the agony because he's
gonna cause us to die to become extinct
much sooner than that by
having our
economy fall to pieces so that's gonna
beat this anyways that's that's my
argument that's my theory there okay
okay uh here's uh
one fellow says i remember hearing how a
chinese ruler took all the money into
his tomb when he died
he also took some slaves with him by the
way they had to die with them uh he
needed them for the afterlife okay i
think they had an economic collapse
there's been many economic collapses we
call them economic collapse when they're
not really economic collapses not the
one i'm talking about i'm referring to
something totally different okay when
people talk about economic collapse they
talk about maybe a recession maybe two
straight quarters of uh negative growth
maybe uh they're talking about a
depression several years of negative
growth or
or just barely breaking even
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about something else when i use
the word economic collapse
i mean one thing and one thing only and
that's that money will be no more trade
will be no more no one trades when money
is no more when no one accepts
money
okay
if no one accepts money what are you
gonna do well people say we're going to
barter i'm going to give me him my car
and he's going to give me my uh give me
his um his boat
that's the way they see it i give you a
television set you give me a radio or
whatever a computer
that's what these people have going
through their minds probably you know
that there's going to be a neighborly
interaction where i trade goods
and the answer is no
absolutely not because the only thing
that's going to be worth of any has any
value after
money is no more will be food food will
be the only thing of value and if you
have food the last thing you're going to
do is trade it
you're not going to give it away for a
car
you're not giving it to give it away for
a
for bitcoin or for
a computer or anything
it's the only thing that's going to keep
you alive for whatever time
uh your food less
you know the when the money is no more
the amount of food you've got in your
cupboard or in your fridge
it's a measure of how much time you have
to live
all right so that's my argument there
and one thought says
so people will always
will accept real objects like gold and
or food dummy
well i don't know there are situations
here's one situation two fellows caught
on an island hopefully a little bigger
than that you know
that's a
such a terrible scenario there and one
guy has a pot of gold has a bag full of
money
do you think uh the other guy has any
use for that money on the island
okay so
their money has no value
and he's got a coconut uh second has a
coconut do you think he's gonna trade
uh the food
for the pot of gold for for the for the
bag of money
well if you do well maybe
you're the dummy
no no there are situations and
situations and uh no we do not trade
when money is no more okay trade dies
completely
nobody trades in fact
the worst uh the the first lesson you're
gonna learn if you're in the asphalt
jungle
and you know you've just realized that
money is no more and nobody accepts your
money
the first lesson you learn is what all
uh wild people
and animals right
humans and the rest of the animal world
what they all know
as a second nature and that is you don't
trust anyone
yet don't trust anyone
you can't go out there and trade
because you're trading your life okay
i i hope that sinks into somebody's head
out there okay you don't trade in the
asphalt jungle
once money is no more trade is dead
okay if you have food you don't trade it
and if you have something else nobody
will trade for you
and if you go in there and insist you're
trading your life
that's the way it works okay so
no uh trade dies when money dies okay
follows us i think the same fellow
dollar dollars are currency and not
money it's not hard to understand
let's look at the definitions okay so we
know if it's hard to understand
apparently this fellow has a tough time
understanding this currency medium of
exchange otherwise known as money what
is money medium of exchange otherwise
known as currency
okay money has relevance only as a
medium of exchange as currency otherwise
money has
no value whatsoever it's abstraction
it's it's in the mind not out there okay
and science we only define uh
one we only have one definition per word
okay so now we do not if if currency and
uh and
dollar or
money are synonyms
well uh then we only have one definition
for them okay we don't have ten
definitions for the word object we have
a single definition for the word object
we don't have 10 definition for the word
exist
okay there's only one definition for the
word exist
those two words are critical in physics
to give a physical interpretation
okay another fellow says uh well looks
like mark karl marx was right capitalism
was going to blow up
um
we've got what is called the mix system
today in every country in the world
beginning with north korea
all the way to the united states from
russia all the way to cuba from china
all the way to south america all
countries are running the same way they
have what is known as a mixed system and
the mixed system is two different
degrees okay uh some countries have a
little more capitalism other countries
have a little more socialism but they're
they all are
if not already they are working towards
having um
health care more or less
subsidized by the state
and
we have schooling which is subsidized by
the state
and uh social security you know your
retirement
that's also done by the state okay every
country in the world almost has that
maybe there's one i missed i don't know
but i think they all have it
okay
so
every country has socialism
and
every country has trade also uh even in
cuba i mean i've been there several
times and
you know there's this black market
you can't stop people from trading
and so uh you know if if especially food
in
cuba they do trade food
and they trade food because we still
have a world running with money okay
that's why food can be traded still okay
but they trade food and so what did they
trade well you know uh
it was strange because when i went there
i bought a family
a whole bunch of meat they hadn't seen
meat in months
and i went to one of these diplo tiendas
as they're called uh it's uh ford they
call it diplomatic tiendas or stores and
only people with passports can go in
there and buy and so i had my passport i
went in there and i bought a bunch of
meat
but also coca-cola they hadn't seen
since the 1950s
and i took it to these people and uh
so he had a great party etc but all the
meat you know i bought too much meat
and the freezers didn't work etc etc etc
and so
they fix the problem very easily
and you learn a lot you know what they
did they went to all the neighbors and
everybody's neighborly over there and
they just gave the food away they gave
the meat away
and so i give you a pound of food of
meat right
and now you owe me a pound of meat
whenever meat comes back to our barrio
to our
store because you can only buy at a
given store in cuba your your
registered at a given store you know you
can't go to this other store over here
because you don't like what they have
over here
first of all they're all the same so it
wouldn't matter anyways but you're tied
to one store and so when food comes in
like
real food like meat
uh then uh joe says hey you owe me you
owe me because i gave you a
kilogram or a pound of
meat uh sometime back and so that's the
way they do it
and
it's called trade
so did paul pott have the right idea
liquidate the cities that's mr pot there
and no um uh he didn't liquidate the
cities
he liquidated the critics
that's what he did supposedly uh paul
pott killed or caused the death of up to
three million people
in cambodia i didn't even know there
were three million people in cambodia
but he caused the death of many people
and he took all these people from the
cities like this gentleman says here
uh
doctors and so on and he says you're
going to the country so he more or less
evacuated the professionals from the
cities he gave him a shovel and says go
work
go do some real work and he got all
these people out into the country and a
lot of them died of disease and
different a lot of them were shot
because they refused to follow orders
and so on and so
big mess uh so yeah
i don't know if the solution is to
evacuate the cities i don't think you
can do that anymore
okay i don't think there's gonna be
you know the cities getting less dense
it's the other way around
cities will become more and more dense
until the whole thing collapses this is
my take on this okay i think the the
once the whole thing collapses
then yeah it's like all the rats leaving
the sinking ship you know they're always
just going to go out there into the
country and look for stuff to eat
but until the collapse of money
i think the cities will just grow
okay what will not happen as far as i'm
concerned is the colonization of new
cities we're not going to found new
cities
maybe one here may one there but i mean
it's we're not gonna
create new cities on the planet tons of
them if anything was going to happen is
in small towns will grow a little
more than they did in the past
people from the country will flock to
villages first maybe those would turn
into city into
towns and from kansas cities something
like that that's the best i can imagine
there but for
new people to go out there in the middle
of nowhere in the middle of the desert
especially the young people and say
we're going to found the city yeah this
is like the christopher columbus kind of
thing you know you you put your flag for
the queen of spain down and you say
i claim this land for the for me
[Laughter]
and you go there with a you know
hundreds of others and you found the
city
not going to happen again
the age of colonization is over no one
is going to do that anymore governments
are not going to sponsor that for sure
they've got bigger problems they got
dead problems right
uh gdp problems so that no one's going
to do that
and the only
exception that i know that i can vouch
to myself
is that the united states creates cities
or in largest little towns
uh by creating by putting prisons
so they put a federal prison right in a
little town
and suddenly all these services pop up
all around it in the city and the little
town groves into a city and the united
states has been pretty good about that
it's found a lot of cities that way by
increasing the um sentencing guidelines
you know the
the sentencing the penalties
so instead of 10 years for
uh
possession of cocaine that will give you
25 years really for
trafficking right and they'll give you
25 years so now you stay there for a
little longer right
and uh and so now you need you have more
population in the system and now you
need to take care of that population so
now you created a way of enlarging the
cities okay
and uh especially you know in my case i
was at eloy
and eloy
grow if you look up eloi the town of
eloy you'll see how much it grew after
1990
which is you know when i was visiting
eloy and the town grew
and you'll see the percentages how the
population grew in eloy it grew why
because
of the prison okay so it's a smart way
of increasing for the government for the
politicians
to to use the drug uh trade to populate
cities
so keep that in mind now of course uh
that was immigration in other words
people migrated from other towns in
there
but uh you get the point the point is
that when people go to a little town
there's more chances also of young
people going in there and reproducing
that's my point okay
okay uh here's another issue ferel says
regarding the transition of economy
agriculture manufacturer service
you said that after service economy all
there will be is unemployment
okay i also say that service is
unemployment services are unemployment
if you work in services like computer
programming internet like me you know
you're unemployed
okay let that be clear why are you
unemployed i'm saying you're unemployed
because you're not producing anything
the the
service economy per se does not produce
anything anything of value
real value what's real value well uh go
up there with god and sit next to god
okay and look down on the earth
whatever is constructed whatever you can
see whatever you could touch if you had
the power of god right
that's what exists
concepts do not exist
love does not exist intelligence does
not exist those concepts do not exist
exist an object that has location what
are the objects we have boats we have
cars we have airplanes we have
houses we have highways
all that exists
okay
because you can touch it no because it
has location with respect to jupiter
okay
and uh
the fields of corn those exist as well
cows those exist
what doesn't exist
is singing
what doesn't exist is insurance
what doesn't exist is bitcoin
none of that exists
okay so anyone who's in any of those
fields
he's not producing anything of value per
se
he thinks he is they call it value okay
but no you're not producing anything
you're living off the fat of the land
that's what we're doing today
we're all living of of what people in
the past built for us
and all we're doing is essentially right
just uh using up
that wealth
right that's what we're doing we're just
spreading it thinner
we're trading you know i'm giving you a
song you give him a computer program the
other guy uh you know fixes the banking
uh
the bank you know the it's a software
and bank receives money from you as a
deposit and then invested all that is
worthless
worthless just like i'm saying worthless
you haven't produced anything the only
time it becomes productive is when it
translates into food or something
tangible such as a new road a new house
etc okay otherwise
we have a world services is unemployment
because it doesn't produce anything and
i know a lot of people say no it
produces value
there's no such thing as value value is
also nonsense the only real stuff is
what exists physics
uh all these concepts that are floating
around there you know they don't exist
okay
those are ghosts
okay but in the off chance that the
economy managed to transition to another
type of economy after the service
economy what kind of economy would it be
hypothetically speaking of course okay
so here it is i've shown this in the
past but here for this gentleman okay
this is the economic modes through the
ages we were hunter gatherers for maybe
200 000 years rounding off 10 000 years
we were farmers agriculturalists
first part we were there as
subsistence agriculturalists subsistence
farmers then we moved into
trade okay so we became commercial
farmers well about 200 300 years ago
okay so-called
industrial revolution we
we started uh
transferring people from the country to
the cities they built machinery for the
country and made
all country work
uh much easier much more efficient and
that kicked more people into the cities
that whole process uh is known as
the industrial revolution i caught
manufacturing we went into the
manufacturing age okay and then from
there on what was it about
around 1980 at least the united states
sweden and some other countries
for the first time services
took over from manufacturing as the as
the number one contributor to gdp and
also the number one um
employment employer okay
more people started becoming white
collar workers and leaving the blue
collars behind
but again i'm saying that's services is
unemployment but anyways even within
that all we can do is maintain that
artificially and what we do we create
services that we don't need
and the only purpose of that is just to
move money around again what is money
it's an abstraction okay we don't we
don't
if you're just gonna
pay money for someone singing neither
you neither the singer uh produced
anything all you did was give some paper
or maybe just transfer a number to their
account and the person sang
and so when all that's over you know god
looks down there and says okay so what
did these two people produce
unless he's got memory he says these
people haven't been doing anything for
the last eight hours
you know uh one guy just transferred a
number and the other guy sang and all
that was
gone with the wind
okay so it's important to know
qualitatively
what our economy and how how our economy
is structured right
okay
someone says intuition says babies and
intelligence are not artificial creation
because i say that um life the word life
especially the words living and alive
i defined them and what i'm saying is
that
something that is alive it has to be an
object that is uh natural it cannot be
artificial it can't be something we made
okay it's got to be something that
mother nature
made okay that's my argument okay right
now i'm just going to put it as a rule
as a law but you're welcome to disagree
and have a different
version okay and this is what this
person is uh is insinuating here yeah
they are man-made objects
we make kids right which makes them
artificial we made the kid
hey hooray we have another son another
gal
china they would bury her and wait for
the guy to come around
so man can or can't make artificial
intelligence
aha
okay so uh let's answer this gentleman
and here's the answer uh it's what we
make with our hands that is artificial
not what we make with our wounds
okay and um you know uh there are some
examples mother nature makes babies
you know a lot of women say god
send her a baby okay
and we make them through wombs and we
make poop through our butts right
and we didn't invent or create babies or
poop
okay
we we haven't created life like with our
hands out here when you create a baby
out here then it's artificial
but when you make it through your inside
you know i mean are we going to say that
rabbits also make babies and so
they make artificial things
okay so we got to keep this in the right
context right i mean it's okay to play
devil's advocate but make sure you you
come back with your feet back to earth
okay
we didn't invent to create babies or
poop it took mother nature thousands of
years of patience to make intelligence
okay
uh our our level of intelligence
intelligence i have uh defined that in
the past okay and i'm not gonna get into
that now but um intel essentially is uh
the cell the cell is the first
intelligent thing it's it's almost
synonymous with life okay
but uh man thinks he's more intelligent
than mama
and wants to do it in decades took
mother nature thousands of years we
think we can do it in a few seconds of
the
universal clock okay
and now it takes a little longer than
a few decades to create life and that's
why and that's a good argument against
the existence of god as well you know
for those of you who propose god as a
hypothesis okay
uh
[Music]
we cannot say that intelligence if
that's what you're gonna say god is
created intelligence first of all
because he already had intelligence
right so what created that intelligence
that's the first issue but then he
couldn't have had created intelligence
at least we have no proof no evidence
okay for those of you who like evidence
and proof like to be convinced
um
you know we have no proof that
intelligence like us top of the line
can create intelligence
we can't create intelligence why do we
think that there's another intelligence
up there that created intelligence down
here
meaning us i guess right so uh yeah we
have no evidence that intelligence can
create intelligence if we're going to
talk in those terms
okay another fellow says or in fact
several people here uh the virus i took
just a couple because there's a lot of
these the virus does not exist it says
for one reason we all have an immune
system that has known the virus for
millions of years regardless of whether
it is a new variant the immune system
remembers its origin and can compare all
variants with the origin and fight them
off
another person says gotta be dumb to get
a vaccine for a virus which doesn't
exist what a joke
okay i did clarify i didn't get a virus
uh the vaccine i got my second shot by
the way
still hurts a little bit yeah almost
nothing a couple days ago okay so i got
the second shot i'm i guess i'm covered
uh did i do it because i was scared that
i was going to get the virus
absolutely no i i took i got the vaccine
only because i'm going to travel and i
don't want the hassle believe me i don't
care about the vaccine one way or the
other but then the question is
does the vaccine does the virus exist do
we need to get shots against this
vaccine maybe it doesn't exist maybe
they're just giving us a shot for
something that's not out there
and all i can do is share with you my
covid flow chart okay so here goes the
flow chart which uh hopefully gets you
to think a little bit uh in the right
direction at least uh
it just helps okay and your reasoning
okay so here it goes okay here's the
covert flow chart and it starts like
this um
we're trying to answer whether the covet
is real or not okay that's the purpose
of the uh flow chart and if you're on
the ultra right ultra left uh no need
apply okay we're just gonna use people
who are
open-minded okay here okay people who um
can think out of box okay
and so um
first question for you is
would cuba iran and other enemies of the
american empire right supposedly one of
the ones who
is in on the secret
on the conspiracy on the hoax right
would they uh cooperate with the u.s
in uh in this hoax
you know and i i can't get an answer to
that question from anyone okay and until
i get an answer to that question
you got to pass that step okay otherwise
you know
you haven't said anything okay and if
you say yes okay that these countries
would all agree the leaders of these
countries who are enemies of each other
that they would put their weapons aside
all their quarrels aside and say okay
for this yeah we're all going to agree
we're going to invent this inexistent
virus we're going to tell each one we're
going to within our countries we're
going to tell our populations that
there's this ravaging disease out there
and we've got to do something about it
well if you think that happens in the
real world
uh
we have to take your voting rights away
from you you don't have enough
mental capacity
to to vote
to understand what politics is about
right
that's my take on that one
and let's look uh let's continue with
the flow chart here if you answered no
then you're a little closer to
rationality and here's the what
continues are there people so mean and
greedy that they would have created the
bug to take over the world
well i mean you know there are
people who are greedy and mean out there
and uh you know if you answered uh
you know uh no
well uh i've got a building i can sell
you you know
i think you're quite naive okay
but if you answered no let me continue
and say could it be
that someone created the bug knowing
right
that there is a solute that there is no
solution to the impending economic
collapse
okay so they create this bug as a
diversion
uh you know tactic
okay and so they say look
we can't fix the problem look it's all
going down hill
all we can do is create more money at
some point we're going to have a crisis
that we can't solve which is creating
more money
and so what do we do well why don't we
create the bug
we create the bug and we uh tell people
look we got this problem everybody's got
to lock down we got to wear masks uh if
you want to travel you got to get the
vaccine you know the whole works right
uh
yeah that's possible we have to consider
it within the laws of probability
impossibility okay that's the first one
and then well would china become uh
implicit in this hoax
okay
in light of the fact that it intends you
know china intends to be the next empire
okay do you think china
again would cooperate with the united
states russia iran
cuba
north korea you know the homeworks do
you think uh that would happen
with all these um
countries agree
that oh we have a big problem with our
global economics and we just got to fool
people for a few more years either to
take over the world and keep
our privileges
or uh
or just stretch it as long as we can do
you think they're there do you think the
the powers that be in china and russia
and the united states especially those
three countries do you think
they already know that the world is
coming to an end
i don't think so
i haven't seen the theory anywhere
my theory that there's gotta be an
economic collapse what i see out there
is something which is misleading and
people confuse with my theory and i keep
getting a lot of people who send me
letters
uh telling me about it but i know it by
heart and they're missing the point
these people the the folks out there
think it's a question of resources
they think it's a question that we have
too much population on earth we have
eight billion people on earth
and we don't have enough
resources metals food etc to feed them
to
keep the world running that's what they
think they think it's an issue of
resources and whenever there's such an
analysis the first thing they do is
introduce irrelevant stuff altogether
climate change oh look climate change
have we're displacing all the animal all
the wild animals
look all the animals are dying all
around us we're in the sixth math
extinction so they bring stuff that has
nothing to do with the subject matter at
all it's like a jack-of-all-trades
they're a cover-all bases
so they say so every time they have the
theory they cover all the bases see oh
look climate change oh we have the sixth
mass extinction uh look at all the
animals that are dying all the plants
that are dying all those species of
plants that are dying
we got to do something
peak oil you know they have all these
arguments and then they throw on top of
that the fact that oh the population on
earth is you know we're beyond um uh
help because we have too much population
in the world already there are not
enough resources to keep keep such
a an increasing population
uh
you know going steady
and so this this is the issue they throw
everything in there and they haven't hit
it on the nose
it has nothing to do this whole thing
has nothing to do
with resources
it has to do with our economic system
you can't keep borrowing money
forever creating money to pay debt
and creating jobs
that don't exist
services that's the problem you can't
keep
creating
uh concepts which is what services does
okay it's all here in the mind it's all
abstract
you can't create concepts and creating
jobs for people saying oh i created a
job and what you created was a concept
you said okay you're a singer now
okay that's my job i sing and so the
person sings he gets a salary and with
that he buys food
okay and what we're doing is simply
feeding
money into the system and not producing
anything real which are the tangible
things out there okay uh the things uh
we can see and touch those who say that
exists and see and touch this is the the
moment where you have to apply that c
and touch okay
so uh yeah it's those things that have
shape and that have location those are
the things we're interested in as far as
uh when we talk about wealth right now
we're not creating wealth at least not
fast enough what we're doing is living
off the fat of the land we're living off
what our forefathers
made for us
okay uh
now the foul says all the countries
don't have to agree for it to be a
conspiracy
oh my god
it can only be a few set in motion by
one
oh can it
the response would be and is uniform no
these are just statements he hasn't
shown that that that's the case okay
it's very easy to imagine a bunch of
rich bastards uh sitting around the
table to come up with a plan for
domination they do it all the time yeah
that's
that second statement doesn't prove the
first one or it doesn't support the
first one okay
and yeah they can sit around and uh
conspiring creep hoaxes and false flags
all that stuff no problem that doesn't
mean that
that first statement all countries don't
have to agree okay my thing for the
so-called banks is it's a new technology
with no track history and what is in it
we have a right to wait yeah i mean i
don't disagree in fact i didn't get a
vaccine for over a year and the reason i
didn't get my vaccine
you know first i don't care about it uh
second i'm not in contact with so many
people out there and so
again like i mentioned in the past
there's a difference between the person
who has to work and works with a lot of
people especially you know in crowded
places that person has a different
situation than the guy who's unemployed
or on welfare or
or you know or social security
retirement like in my case you know and
you know uh those those are different
situations
and so i don't have to worry because i
think the
statistically the chances of me catching
that virus are slim
that's the way i look at it okay is
there a virus out there i think there is
because again i don't think all these
enemies would agree on a hoax okay
that's the main one unless you can
answer that question
you don't have a
foot to stand on okay but once we can
see the virus am i worried about it no
i'm not worried because again the
chances of me catching that virus are
slim even if i catch it maybe i have
automatic you know uh natural defenses
and
if not well i die in my case i'm 69
going on 69 this year
so you know i'm too much to live anyways
and so if i die a little earlier uh
all
that happened was i drank less beer
that's it
so
my situation is different than yours if
you're 20 years old and you work with a
lot of people well you know you might be
a little more worried than me
okay and again the only reason i got my
shot is not because i i bought the
people up there who gave the orders
nothing like that at all it's just
because you know these people are
hassling everyone who travels and so you
know i don't want the hassle that's it
okay final issue fella says definition
of life again
who laughs at irrational biologists for
thinking menopausal uh women who who
stop reproducing are no longer alive
well uh no
uh yes and no in a way yeah and i'm
saying that the problem here is that the
establishment biologists they have to
this day no definition of the word life
in other words they don't know what a
thing that is a live
is or means you know what that word
means
they can't define the word alive they
don't know what a living thing entity is
and biology is what the study of
living entities
and so if you don't know what a living
entity is
what kind of biologist are you
and so they have created all these
uh
properties i guess you could say uh or
attributes it's a person who can
reproduce
grow blah blah breathes etc and none of
those apply to all living entities
that's the problem
and so they don't have a definition they
have all these things and well you know
what i mean
no no i don't
because you got the wrong definition
so i have a definition but this person
doesn't like it or he complains about it
or
place devil's abdicate on it okay no
problem but doesn't look at himself in
the mirror when his organism stopped
living when they stop flying jumping
climbing ladders against gravity and go
to sleep
so let's put the definition of life
of the establishment here so we can
compare side by side okay
and it goes like this says life the
condition that distinguishes animals and
plants for inorganic matter
yeah okay and what is that including
capacity for growth reproduction
functionality activity la la
okay
so they just mention a bunch of
properties that not all animals have but
they say this is the best definition
we've got
and wikipedia the same thing life is a
characteristic that distinguishes
physical entities okay at least uh they
they don't think of pixels you know
that have biological processes such as
signaling and self-sustaining processes
and they go from the same thing you know
they essentially list
it's a list of properties okay
what do we put in exchange to this well
we say that alive living
a natural object that moves against the
path of least resistance essentially a
living being has the ability to move
against gravity something a rock does
not okay and life is a group of living
beings
okay so those are the definitions
and yeah this file doesn't like that
definition but he says that
i'm saying that for example if my uh
aunt
she never had babies in fact she did she
was not able to have children was she
alive
and
is my grandmother alive
after you know the age of 60 when she
can have no more babies
okay so
obviously you know
having children
is not a criterion that should be used
to define the word living and so this is
what this follows making fun of but i'm
saying
the
you know the the first entity
that we can call living alive is the
cell
okay
the cell is the first living entity
dna is not alive
virus is not alive
virus and dna rna and all these others
they are molecules
that's all they are they're just
molecules do they have the ability to
move by themselves the answer is no
okay they can't move against gravity
specifically but they can't move by
themselves what happens is when
uh they're in a body when they're in a
cell
they uh all these make rep then that's
where they go to work they start moving
they start creating
copies of themselves
okay
and at least that's the theory okay and
so that's when
uh viruses and molecules move
chemically and otherwise okay
electromagnetic
motion
van der waals
forces etc uh so that's when they start
moving the cell is the first entity that
moves on its own
and so it doesn't matter if you're
sleeping or not your cells are moving
okay inside your body
not so the uh
rocks now
you can take it as far as you want you
can say well do atoms move inside rocks
uh or are they so rigid that they don't
move
and yeah the answer is uh
atoms you know expand and contract
okay so is an atom alive
and yeah you can take it as far as you
want
we have to use a word life in order to
def to have biology the study of life
okay
explanations uh
in the living world
and so we have to have a definition for
that
the definition again is that which can
move against gravity that's the only
difference between a living entity and a
rock okay
now uh
why do i exclude artificial things you
know airplanes fly balloons float you
know etc and they move against gravity
as well yeah because if you want to
include it again i say no problem go
ahead include it
but you better have some use for it for
that definition this is not a question
defining for the sake of defining it's a
question of defining so that we can use
the definition for some purpose in
science and so we distinguish artificial
things from living things because we're
used to the word living referring to
what mother nature made that's why i
exclude all artificial
entities okay
now you want to include it in there no
problem but make sure you have a reason
to do so okay and that's where
i think this person's going to fail and
everybody who just wants to play devil's
advocate and says
let's include artificial things because
they move against gravity as well no you
can't do that because we have no use for
that definition
okay with that we move on to
physics
physics proper okay and i've been
looking at transparency and opacity and
reflection refraction as as
subgroups of those okay
and uh let's do a little recap here real
quick
and this is what i've covered i'm saying
there's at least
four mechanisms or variables you should
consider when looking at opacity and
transparency how does mother nature do
this magic trick where here something is
opaque and over here something is
transparent okay you got to figure out
how mother nature does that magic trick
okay why can't i see through a window
and i can't see through a wall
something's different about those okay
okay and so i mentioned already these uh
mechanisms or variables that you should
consider alignment is one okay and
uh covered that meaning that uh if you
have
polarization okay the two polarizers are
parallel
you can see right through them you know
if someone shines a uh laser
through those two polarizers you will be
able to see the laser the the light goes
through and reaches your eye or whatever
on the other hand if you turn it 90
degrees one of the polarizers with
respect to the other the beam is
extinguished and you don't see the beam
anymore
okay so apparently mother nature does
transparency and opacity by just
rearranging the direction of the
molecules in other words
the direction in which they point to
tilt
okay
orientation
uh that has something to do with opacity
that's one of the ways mother nature
does uh you know um
opacity and transparency and i call it
alignment right next one quantity you
know you showed one sheet in fact i
think
i don't have it here anyways you have
one sheet of something that's
transparent you put a whole bunch of
sheets like glass
you put many sheets of glass a thin
glass the same glass that you can see
through in your house you put many of
those it becomes greenish and at some
point it becomes opaque
so here's something that was transparent
only because of its thinness
becomes completely opaque
did i say
something is transparent when it's very
thin it becomes opaque when you put many
of those
okay so again quantity is another way
another variable you should consider
i mentioned temperature the fact that
you know uh like air
you know if you freeze it well uh sun
suddenly you can see air
okay but when it's uh very hot meaning
in a gaseous state you can't see the air
okay
and uh so temperature has something to
do with it okay but there's keep in mind
there's the other side of the coin to
that and that's that
you know if you take argon
uh it's more or less transparent when
it's solid or liquid but what's when
it's in a gaseous state
you know it's a uh
a uh
violet uh purplish
uh color so it's no longer transparent
now it's become
opaque
okay so
keep that in mind okay but again
temperature seems to have something to
do with it that's my point and then i
talked about rigidness stiffness of
material molecular structure you know
usually we associate opacity with stuff
which is rigid like walls okay like
cement walls bricks steel beams
and anything that is tending towards
liquid and gas is usually or we
associate those with things that are
transparent
okay
so apparently the molecular structure
which is also a function of temperature
has something to do with it okay
but i have concluded quantum mechanics
provides no physical interpretation for
transparency or opacity okay
and again what i'm trying to do here is
i'm trying to give you tools so that you
can figure it out on your own
okay i want you to think because
otherwise i don't know if you learned
anything yeah if i tell you all the
answers you say oh okay and you just
memorized it for the test and then
you know you don't really understand it
the way you're going to understand if
you've got to figure it out for yourself
once you have the tools and so don't ask
what bill can do for you ask what you
can do for bill don't ask tell me
tell me why air and water are
transparent and why a brick is not
okay so that's that's how that's the
purpose of these uh last few lectures
okay
and uh so why
can't quantum mechanics why hasn't
quantum mechanics provided
a physical interpretation
for transparency or opacity
and people say but they have billy
you're just
out of the
out of time
you haven't heard you you come back you
got to come in from 19th century
okay here it is uh we had this fella uh
nick lucid he's uh has his own channel
there and he summarizes essentially what
the establishment believes it says when
a photon comes along the electron gets
excited and jumps to a higher energy
level okay that's the bottom line
okay what quantum mechanics says the way
they explain this is that a photon hits
an electron bead that is circling the
nucleus of the atom and it bumps it off
into a higher energy level okay that's
that's the idea okay it either does or
it doesn't it depends on how much energy
that photon has
and he continues says an electron in a
gas molecule releases a photon okay an
electron a liquid or solid molecule the
other molecules are too close and the
electron calms down by releasing that
energy to adjacent molecules increases
the thermal energy instead of releasing
a photon in other words that photon
energy which i guess their synonyms uh
is
transferred to molecules next the
neighboring molecules and so they
vibrate they absorb that heat that
energy or they they
essentially release it as heat okay a
photon that does not excite an electron
lacks what a high enough energy to boost
it to a higher level band or orbital
is still absorbed by the electron but
immediately rejected so the electron
absorbs it but rejects it in other words
spits it back out
and does not jump to a higher energy
level that's what he's saying okay and
this is a standard quantum mechanics
here okay the energy gap in glass is too
big for visible light okay
to excite an electron the photon has to
have an energy of at least 138
nanometers and that's uv light meaning
it's outside the visible range okay if
visible light cannot excite an electron
it won't get absorbed as thermal energy
it still gets absorbed just as
vibrations in the electron instead okay
and since the electrons uh reject these
uh photons they make it out the other
side and he
uh exclaims uh triumphantly transparency
in other words if uh just uh to
summarize
a photon comes in
it gets absorbed by the electron
if if
if it absorbs it uh
it could it has a couple possibilities
one is releasing it as heat to the
neighbors and the other one is
uh releasing it uh jumping to a higher
energy level okay and the other one is
it absorbs it but the energy of the
photon is not high enough so it does
it's not strong enough you could say or
you know whatever and it doesn't hit
that electron to the higher energy level
in which case the photon
either passes by doesn't get absorbed by
the electron or gets absorbed by the
electron and spit out back again
okay so
different people explain it different
ways those are the options okay you have
to understand that in order to
understand all my criticisms here
because a lot of people are off on the
wild blue yonder you know i'm talking
about nonsense and they don't answer
that issue they don't seem to understand
that that's what quantum says
okay
so what does quantum say
photon is absorbed and released
if it released or it doesn't absorb it
at all then the photon continues and
that's why a
an object is transparent
any body a substance is transparent
okay so i hope we got that uh okay and
why is that nonsense well first of all
um
quantum doesn't have particles what
you're seeing here are really corpuscles
because you see something there that's
not the core puzzle or the particle of
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics has
a zero dimensional point particle as
they call it they use the word particle
when they don't mean particle the word
particle is misleading it's there to
confuse people the the word particle of
quantum is not an object it's a concept
okay and it means uh wave function
collapse
because they're not interested in the
architecture or the structure of the
entity known as a photon or an electron
they just want to be able to know where
to locate it
okay so they're not interested in
structure at all no mathematician in
earth ever
was concerned about that well maybe i
can't say ever but certainly since the
last hundred years they have not been
interested in architecture at all they
don't care about architecture they don't
care about structure they don't use
objects in quantum mechanics they just
use
mathematical concepts abstractions so
that's the first problem and the second
one is that they use this transverse
wave
which um
what is what is waving
and
what they're insinuating
you know
uh is that it's particles so we're back
to particles what are the particles zero
dimensional point nothing's okay that's
what they are but actually the
transverse wave invented by uh
essentially mr maxwell james maxwell
uh just a bunch of vectors it's a
mathematical concept it has nothing to
do with physics
the wave of quantum mechanics or
classical mechanics you could say
it's just a bunch of vectors that's what
those blue and red arrows are just
magnitude and direction
and what they have is magnitude and
direction which is moving sideways
very scary stuff so quantum mechanics
does not or mathematical physics in
general right
doesn't have a physical object
to do physical interpretations
so their stuff has nothing to do with
physics
okay physics is what physical
interpretations
explanations rational explanations right
of physical phenomena and that's not
what they do what they do is describe
what they have is
uh mathematical physics in general in
fact all of it is it's just descriptions
what is an equation a description it's a
description of motion of how something
behaves
so they can't tell you what gravity is
they cannot tell you what is mediating
gravity in that invisible intangible
world of we call gravity
what they can do is tell you how fast an
object that they can see and touch falls
to the ground
that they can tell you because they can
measure they give you the equation and
that's all they provide they say that's
gravity
but we don't know what gravity is
because in order to know
to understand
to explain what gravity is give a
physical interpretation you need a
physical object you need to make the
invisible object that mother nature uses
you have to make it visible
okay so you have to
draw
what you think mother nature is using
you have to make what an assumption
of what mother nature could be using to
mediate gravity light
magnetism the whole works
okay and that's what no one in
mathematical physics does that's why the
physics part of that title mathematical
physics is uh excess baggage it's just
mathematics
that's all it is what they do
okay and so here we have looks at this
look at this trickery one guy objects to
my um
one-way mirror they got two-way mirror i
don't agree with that term
uh because you can only see one way
that's what a one-way mirror is why they
call two-way mirror wrong it's not
two-way one-way is mirrored the other
way it's glass
you can see in one direction you can't
in the other that's what it's all about
so i call it a one-way mirror
that is a mirror on two sides and yet
you can see through it in both
directions yeah see uh none of these
people answer the question now here's uh
here's the issue okay this is what
people have to figure out let me put it
over here
okay
the man
sees a man he sees himself
in the mirror the woman
she's looking through the same glass
from the other side
and she sees the man she doesn't see
herself okay so she sees a man he sees a
man he sees himself she sees him
meaning the light from him went to her
eye
the light from her did not go to his eye
okay do we have that that's what a
one-way mirror is
now what's the issue the issue is we
have uh uh because some people say well
it's the coding
that when it's on one side and the other
people say well um what you have here is
a uh it's the
lighting in the room
here it's dark over here it's light
irrelevant
irrelevant irrelevant
okay
it's irrelevant because it's irrelevant
to the question
that quantum mechanics
answers
quantum mechanics says what
photon comes in if the electron does not
absorb it it sends it out or it never
picks it up in the first place and so
the photon goes through
as if it
found nothing you know between the thing
in your eye
okay that's what quantum mechanics says
here we have a mirror that's the only
thing standing between the gal and the
guy
okay
we shine a laser from one side
the girl sees it
we shine the laser from the other side
the man does not see it
in fact when he points his laser to the
mirror he gets a reflection in the
mirror he doesn't see
the girl
okay
so now the laser is the same one
has nothing to do with a room
it has nothing to do with the coding
has to do with here we're talking about
just the laser light the the beam the
photons that make up the laser just the
laser the red beam 620 nanometers
whatever okay
so we're only talking about the photons
that make up the laser beam
they have to go through the same
thickness
of material which is that
glass slash mirror
okay
whether it goes in one direction or in
the other direction it's the same amount
of material same atoms same molecules in
between
you know the the the two lasers
okay so the photons of the lasers from
one side and the other have to go
through the same amount of material
why doesn't the electron
of any atom
pick up
the laser
in one direction it does so in the other
direction
okay all we have is a difference in
direction
the the beam is the same the photons are
the same they have the traverse the same
amount of material they're picked up in
one direction they're not picked up in
the other direction and it's the same
material in between the two lasers
that's the question you have to answer
and that destroys the the the ants the
uh yeah the answer that quantum
mechanics gives
quantum mechanics says
that's what we're attacking with this
we're saying that quantum has the wrong
explanation
it's not a question of absorbing photons
because the photons would be absorbed in
either direction
okay i hope that went through somebody's
head out there
okay so uh i is that clear
okay let me move on here
okay
um
fellow says also attacks this as there
are two factors determining speed of
sound density and rigidity the denser a
medium is the slower sound travels but
but the stiffer the faster okay so he's
more or less
regurgitating what i said last time okay
obviously water and iron
and iron are uh much denser than air but
they are also much stiffer so sound is
faster instead of slower okay helium and
hydrogen are lighter than air but the
speed of sound is faster in them too
okay so he's uh just putting out a lot
of facts okay opacity and reflect uh
reflectivity i guess he meant are
probably in large part a function of the
change in stiffness across a boundary
the rote and twist backwards instead of
twerking
and
especially stiff adam okay uh
the good thing is that at least i got
the guy to think okay and i wish more
people would do that
like he did in other words he's trying
to analyze it he said i'm giving him the
tools he's going out there trying to
figure out okay why is this
transparent why is that opaque and why
do we have some contradictions in the
sense that uh some stiff things are
transparent some gases
maybe liquid things are not
and so it's not only stiffness there's
some other
factors working in okay so again i'm
giving you the tools you got to put them
together you got to put the puzzle
together to figure out why air
glass
uh
water are transparent and why a brick is
not okay
okay so um
here's what he was referring to the fact
that you know you have sound going
through uh something which is solid like
steel
through liquid such as water and through
a gas such as air
and you can see that sound travels
faster through the solid than through
the liquid and liquid faster than
through gas
okay and so the question is is this a
good analogy
for um
for how light behaves is can we can we
extrapolate that verbatim
to or the mechanism to
light
and i'm saying no you cannot okay that
was my argument my argument was you
cannot why because
in the case of sound it has to do with
molecules
okay
you don't you don't have sound out there
in space
even if the
um
astronauts could take off their you know
little hat
and they could shout at each other
assuming they they could breathe or
whatever
they wouldn't be able to hear because
you need vibrations of the molecules to
carry that sound okay
that's not the case with
light
but it should be
it should be because you say well you
know there's no
no atoms and obviously
light does not require vibrations of
atoms that means light is not the
vibration of atoms
but then they have this ether which is
what everybody used in the last 400
years they said there's ether out there
something
tiny where are they referring to a bunch
of particles
and quantum has now proved it to
themselves
mathematicians they say look
the vacuum is made of particles
you have particles popping in from the
void
positive and negative
and when they recombine they annihilate
meaning they turn into a space particle
because that's where the next particle
is going to come out separate and become
these two particles so they're talking
about particles and they're saying
there's this invisible
particle world out there then we'll call
it an ether because that's the word
that's always been used which means a
bunch of particles and so if there's if
space itself is made of a bunch of
particles and that's what's vibrating
when you talk about a wave then we're
talking about the vibrating
of or vibration of
all these gazillions of particles
and that's what light would be under the
quantum mechanics
or mathematical physics in general
so so again is space made out of
particles and if it is
you know they don't don't uh we have a
partic uh uh problem because we're
saying that light is the vibration of
those particles
okay
and is is that what quantum wants to
accept is that what they're going to
vouch for
you know again that's the question they
never answer they leave it out there and
they talk about waves but they don't
tell you what what it is that's waving
but what they're insinuating is that
what's waving are particles
and what are those particles well space
is made out of particles
but they they're not very clear on that
no one out there has really grasped that
very well the general public i mean but
that's what they're insinuating okay so
keep that in mind
uh this this is what they have going
through their minds
okay um and another fellow made a
comment also and he said uh to me the
theory that gravity and atomic molecular
alignment have a lot to do with
transparency as torsion waves get
relayed along the roads from atom to
atom makes a lot of sense okay in the
case of water my guess would be that the
effect is
enhanced because both gravity and the
shape of the water molecule
a v shape remember the water molecule is
kind of like that you got the
oxygen and two hydrogens okay
uh result in a stacking of the molecules
whereby creating a sort of lattice okay
just take again people who are reasoning
trying to figure out why materials are
transparent now the h atoms are aligned
and there's lower interference in the
relay i would expect that even under
motion water would for the most part
retain this configuration and disrupt
and any disruptions would not last
sufficiently long to disrupt
transparency another molecule that has
this v shape is sio2 glass right
coincidence
well let me correct them on that second
on that second issue
okay uh no
sio2 according to this fellow here is a
linear molecule okay
electron geometry of sio2 is linear
because no lone pair of electrons is
present on the silicon okay this is what
he says
okay and you can see that there's a
difference with the h2o
um
which is 104 degrees okay
so what is uh
you could say triangular the other one's
linear okay
that's the first issue
but uh the second issue is the fact that
this fellow at least tries to break his
brain trying to figure out
you know how to how to explain
transparency and that's good all i can
do is give you the tools and say look
these are the things you got to watch
out for on the rope model you can apply
it now to transparency and opacity and
find out exactly how mother nature does
this magic trick
okay
now
should i tell you if if i tell you
uh will you believe me first
then uh the issue is you know have you
learned
or have you just memorized
you know it's nice for you to figure out
how the magician did the trick on stage
and not go to the locker room and say uh
how did you do that trick
no no try to figure it out if you can't
figure out spent 10 years figuring it
out okay then you then you're thinking
otherwise the guy said well this is how
i did it oh okay that's so easy yeah
and maybe you didn't understand it
okay so uh what was this felt talking
about well he's talking about this
here i have my son who uh
turned water on its side and the
question is
what did he do did the molecules of
water uh move
like the one on the top or the one on
the bottom
did the
molecules rotate or did they maintain
their fixed position with respect to the
center of the earth due to gravity okay
so that's the question for you to ponder
okay
and that's what this fellow is analyzing
okay but today we're going to go with a
fifth uh mechanism or variable that you
should consider another factor okay
and here it is this is uh it's got to do
with frequency okay it's known as veen's
uh
displacement law
some kind of wean
beam
uh the lower the temperature the longer
the wavelength
another way of stating that wavelengths
are inversely proportional the
temperature we talked about temperature
okay and also the rigidity of the
material
the colder it is
the
uh stiffer it is okay temperature
another way of
stating uh wings law temperature
directly proportional to frequency
okay
that's the one we're looking at down at
the bottom you can see that temperature
there's the thermometer at the bottom
way at the bottom
uh
is in direct uh proportion to frequency
the higher the frequency the higher the
temperature
okay
uh
so
we this is the notion we have out there
what's the problem the problem is we see
a little snake there a little squiggly
line we don't know what that is what is
that
well they say that's a wave
and one issue is wave of what and what
is that illustration of is that a string
is is that what they're showing there a
string that's
you know folded several times
no they they just put that in there but
there's no physical object in quantum
that looks like that
what they talk about is particles and
particles ain't particles they're not
corpuscles what they are is point
particles meaning
wave function collapses or vibrating
fields or whatever they want to call it
okay in other words there is no such
thing as a wave
and that's the big problem and here's a
here's another vision of this spectrum
okay and you can see it there the
visible part is a very small part uh of
the entire spectrum when you get to the
uh high end gamma razor high vibrations
apparently and radio waves are on the
other extreme and again we see that
squeaky snake there
what is that squiggly snake what is a
wave
so there is no physical object called
wave first of all then you won't see it
in the standard model of quantum
mechanics
what you'll see is what they call
particles
and those particles ain't particles
so we got problems all around with with
the physical interpretations of quantum
mechanics
no wonder richard finan says no one
understands quantum mechanics yeah no
kid
because you haven't
set the foundations for your theory
you haven't identified the objects that
mother nature uses
why because you can't see or touch them
so no experiment no equation is going to
elucidate what that invisible intangible
world out there looks like the only way
is to drink a couple beers sit back and
think try to visualize what mother
nature could be doing in that invisible
intentional world of hers
okay um
so here we have uh what the
so-called wave of mathematics is and you
can see it's not a physical object they
call it the electromagnetic wave came
from mr
maxwell
actually you know they had the
transverse wave already came by uh
augustine fred now okay french guy
he came up with the transverse notion
and they were putting it together
between
him and
james maxwell going through faraday in
between but this is what they came up
with
and what are we staring at well we're
staring at a bunch of arrows
you know those blue and red arrows
what are those engine arrows
and no those arrows represent vectors in
other words they put something physical
that you could see but what it
represents is an abstraction it
represents a vector and what is a vector
well its magnitude and direction that's
what it is so you're talking about
something mathematical that has nothing
to do with the physical world
okay and what is a field well it's a
bunch of moving vectors that's what a
field is so a magnetic field and an
electric field are just moving vectors
moving what magnitudes and directions
and forget about directions just
magnitudes
and then what is a wave well a wave is
just
made of two fields and what are the
fields doing they're waving
are they waving up and down like when
you move a string like a standing wave
no they're uh
they're moving who knows how
because uh they just say they move they
they just represent this mathematically
and so that's what the wave is
the electromagnetic wave they say that's
what light is that's the
physical representation of light
electromagnetic wave
and so far we have nothing in front of
us all we have is a mathematical
calculation
of uh
vectors and motion
that's all we have okay
okay so let's compare it against the
rope so that we know what the
differences are the one on the top is
what mathematical physics proposes again
a bunch of uh fields what are those uh
abstract mathematical concepts just
traveling vectors
rope proposes a physical object we're
saying there's a rope there that you
can't see or touch
okay
and uh yeah if uh you want to see her
touch it just ask the people in quantum
and they'll tell you that you can't see
or touch light you can't see or touch
gravity
the mediator of gravity or you can't see
or touch with your hand right or with
your eyes right uh
magnetism the whatever is doing
magnetism so so that means there's no
physical object in that
region
there's nothing mediating light there's
nothing mediating magnetism there's
nothing absolutely nothing mediating
gravity
well if you think like that then you're
essentially introducing black magic into
your theory into your explanation
and so now we introduce a physical
object that's a 3d
rope
like entity it looks more or less like
dna like a rope anyway you want to
visualize it that's what we're proposing
that's the assumption
that that's what mediates light
and so now we can talk about frequency
okay which is uh another way mother
nature does uh
transparency and opacity so what is it
okay well we start by saying that we do
have an equation it's a wave equation c
velocity of light 300 000 kilometers per
second okay
c equals frequency times wavelength when
frequency goes up wavelength goes down
when wavelength goes up frequency goes
down they're inversely proportional
the only entity imaginable that can
represent that equation is a rope a
rope-like entity looks more or less like
this okay okay
and the more you torque it
the
shorter the links and the more links you
have
more links frequency
shorter links
the longer the links
okay the longer this the fewer links you
have
frequency has gone down wavelength has
gone up that's what we're showing there
with a 4 8 and 16.
and
um
like we just said a minute ago uh the
spectrum right
uh low frequency is identified with cold
with the infrared red region of the
spectrum okay
and what we're talking about is longer
wavelengths
and uh
shorter
or
smaller frequency shorter frequency in
other words uh you have more
lengths per length
per rope length okay
and as you go up uh higher you torque
the rope more and more and more and more
and more well at some point you get into
the ultraviolet range which is on the
other side of the
on the upper side of the visible
spectrum okay
high frequency is related to hot so cold
low frequency rigidity
high frequency hot
typically gases you know water and gas
if you freeze water
you get it colder okay what happens it
gets solid and what do we do what we did
was change the lengths
of
the ropes okay the number of lengths and
the length length
okay so that's
the overall proposal that's the theory
okay
and
so yeah uh so here we have it
an example
of air versus a wall
a wall
uh
absorbs that light that
you know the the rope ends in a
an atom that forms the wall but that
atom is in a rigid structure which is
the wall
why is the wall rigid
well because it's cold
okay
if we heat up the wall like throw it
inside the sun
it evaporates it turns into
gas whatever molecules whatever atoms
the wall is made out of go whoop they
lose that rigid structure
okay
so the wall is only solid when it's cold
which is its normal state here on earth
so we look at a wall we just take it for
granted oh okay there's a wall
those atoms
that form that wall
you know they're cold
okay for uh room temperature for them
it's cold very cold
you you want to evaporate them you want
them to move around maybe turn into
liquids and gases well then you got to
heat it up and throwing inside the sun
will guarantee that that wall will
turn into some kind of gas for sure
okay so what happens while it's still
solid while it's still cold
meaning what
uh
low frequency
uh longer links okay
so what happens uh you have light coming
in to an atom
and it doesn't relay because that's the
explanation for transparency right
under the rope model relay from one atom
to another
but what happens because it's in a rigid
structure it absorbs that
impact okay
and so what comes out is a longer length
link
light does go through the wall
in a sense in other words what it is is
being relayed through the wall but you
can't see it because
the rigidness of the wall because it's
cold because it doesn't like that
frequency okay what it does is absorb
the impact of that torsion
and when it relays it it relays it at a
longer
length link length
okay and so it's beyond the visible
range on the other side
but yeah light so to speak quotations
here right goes through walls
always
but what do we mean by that means it
relays light from one atom to the next
through the ropes that interconnect them
except that
when it comes out of the other side it
doesn't um relay it faithfully as it
came in came in at high frequency
visible range we'll call that the high
frequency here okay
and it comes out at a low frequency
below
uh the infrared
okay
air on the other hand
uh
relays it exactly or more or less
exactly there's very little difference
in the refractive index of air and
vacuum okay but we'll assume it it
relays it faithfully okay like if it
were a vacuum but that's what it does it
more or less relays it faithfully to the
other side okay
now people say well why does it do it
bill
uh
that's for you to figure out okay i'm
giving you the tools i'm saying
frequency is another factor you have to
consider because it's related to
temperature and to rigidity to the
factors we talked about the other day so
all three of them are intertwined okay
we have temperature rigidity and
frequency they all have something to do
with each other okay what is frequency
it's a question of temperature what is
temperature it's a question of rigidity
okay they're all tied
okay
so uh when you analyze this you have to
include all of them together and
you know you have to
juggle them in such a way that you can
explain
once you have these tools why water air
glass are transparent why a brick wall
is not or steel beam is not
okay
let's move on here
these are the walls okay let me make
that a little bigger
there you see the walls okay and um
light the rope essentially interconnects
all atoms in any of those media in other
words when the light from the sun comes
to your eye
okay it's really being relayed through
all the atoms of air that form the
barrier between the
uh surface of the earth and you know the
sun
so we have all this air covering our
planet and each one of those atoms is
actually relaying the light from one
atom to the next until it reaches your
eye it does so at the speed of light so
light always goes through all these
walls
in in a sense and as it's relayed
through each one of these walls okay
and what you have to do your job is to
look at the tools i gave you you know
trans uh to
explain transparency and opacity you
have the tools alignment okay
and um
quantity how many we have okay
um
frequency which we
talked about now and the other two which
are rigidity and
uh in other words molecular structure
and then uh which one did i miss um
i missed the other one i'll get in a
second i get it here
okay so uh first thing we have to
destroy this notion of travel through
going through moving through there's no
such
moving through as quantum says because
for that you would have to use maybe
particles or waves and
we can't use particles or waves as we
just saw
so you can't use particles or waves to
give a physical interpretation to
transparency and so those people who use
the term going through passing through
moving through they have to explain or
first they have to start by identifying
what physical object is moving through
passing through
going through
okay
so no uh waves and particles do not move
through glass because
the waves aren't waves and the particles
aren't particles
those are not physical entities that's
why we have to define the word object in
science to get rid of particles and
waves okay no such monsters in physics
you have to identify the physical object
first job of a physicist you don't
identify a physical object you are not a
physicist
okay you're a religious individual who
just memorized stuff in high school in
college and just regurgitates them
for a physical interpretation which is
not physical at all
conclusions okay and i think you're okay
there we have it what did i miss
temperature with yellow okay
five mechanisms mother nature uses to do
transparency refraction or opacity uh
reflection
and what do we have we have alignment
okay the polarization thing um
quantity
temperature
stiffness and frequency
and what is the icing on the cake icing
on the cake the little
cherry
uh quantum mechanics provides no
physical interpretations for
transparency or opacity why not well
because they don't have physical objects
particles are not particles are not
corpuscles right
waves are made of particles
and
if not
they're made like some mathematicians
say out there they're made of absolutely
nothing
and nothing is made of particles
okay let's go with the questions we had
since last time comments one file says
does the rope form things besides atoms
what else can a rope weave into in your
opinion
well
some of these people you know they they
should start by
learning the abcs they they want to go
they ask college questions and they
haven't gone through kindergarten
or elementary school
they have to start at the beginning and
the first thing is uh they and they
never learn to talk okay
and so the key issue there is the word
opinion
okay so let's educate this individual
opinions
is a definition or a synonym of religion
okay religion is opinions and beliefs so
we don't have opinions and beliefs in
science what we have is assumptions
okay
and so uh
you know it's not a belief
the question is when someone gives a
presentation okay
uh for example in a conference or
whatever physics science
they have to make an assumption about
the objects
and so he says in your opinion it's not
a question of opinion it's a question
making an assumption he can make the
assumption
he can talk about unicorns if he wants
you know he can introduce god if he
wants that's his assumption
does it mean you're going to accept his
assumption are you going to challenge
his assumption sure you can challenge
his assumption
but but it's not a question of belief he
cannot come in there to the conference
say
it is my opinion
i believe
no because now he's moved into religion
he's talking about something else that
has nothing to do with science in
science we say let us assume
let us assume there are neutrons let us
assume there are electrons let us assume
they are weed by
threads another person can make a
different assumption he can say let us
assume the election is a little bead let
us assume
it rolls around the atom
and then he explains his theory
and then your job is to say well hold it
i challenge you
i challenge you to what well i challenge
you to a duel
what are you challenging you're saying
well why doesn't that electron be your
assumption you know
why does it fall to the nucleus why
doesn't spontaneously fly away
why does it roll around
within orbitals and then jumps back and
forth between energy levels or whatever
that's what he's going to explain if he
can't explain that he doesn't have a
starting point he can't even explain his
theory his theory is bunk
so we're talking about physical
interpretations
not math not experiments not predictions
we're talking about give me an
explanation of how mother nature runs
her shop
and the way you're going to have to do
it is beginning by telling me what your
atom looks like and it better not be a
little bead going around
the the proton okay like mr
niels bohr said verner heisenberg and
all these people
no you can't use that model the
planetary model which is the model they
use to explain
not only quantum jump that's the one
they explain use for ionization you know
the electron beam flies away for
whatever reason being pulled off i guess
or spit off
and that's how i explained electricity
so you can't use those that atom to
explain any of those phenomena because
your atom is bunk
is nonsense
poppy cup okay
okay uh phil says another one with
question uh college question without
having gone through
kindergarten okay so is there a rational
reason for the ropes to be twisted
why the ropes torque
my god
so many things wrong with that question
but let's see if we can summarize here
this is it okay pay attention
okay uh here are the questions uh why is
the speed of light 300 000 kilometers
per second
why is there something rather than
nothing
you've heard that question before
probably
and feynman richard feynman nobel prize
in 1965 he says why did aunt minnie go
to the hospital he says in his
you can caught explanation his lack of
an explanation for magnetism and you can
look him up on youtube you'll find
firemen and magnets and that's where he
tells you this little story about and
minnie breaking her leg and going to the
hospital why did that many go to the
hospital
all these are irrational questions
in physics
okay
uh and again
feynman never learned uh physics
and no idea what physics was about
especially if he can doesn't understand
the question the difference between
a question of physics and a question of
philosophy so what he's asking is a
question of philosophy and he's phrasing
it in an answer
to a question of physics which is how
does a magnet work so he uses this as an
example meaning he had no clue
whatsoever the difference between
philosophy and physics
okay
and yeah all these are irrational
questions why is the speed of light 300
000 kilometers per second why is that an
irrational question well because the
answer to all these questions is really
uh the first two
is uh
because god said so
okay that's the answer the answer is god
wanted it that way
okay
we inherited a universe that already has
the speed of light and we already
inherited a universe that has
matter in it
okay
why is there something rather nothing
and that matter is already in motion so
you cannot ask why is there motion
either for example
all those are irrational questions
because you're asking a question of
purpose
of reason
of why someone did something
in the context of physics
you're asking you're essentially putting
god already
in your picture you're saying why did
god make the speed of like 300 000
kilometers per second why did god make
something rather than nothing why did
god put
things in motion that's what you're
asking
you're asking a question of purpose and
reason and not a question of what
mechanisms
and
causes okay
and that's why these are irrational
questions
they're they're philosophy questions
reason and purpose those are questions
of philosophy
and you can't mix philosophy with
physics okay you want to do philosophy
do philosophy okay you can't ask a why
question of that nature the why
questions have to be related to causes
and mechanisms
why did the
pen falter earth you know
meaning what caused what's the mechanism
then you're asking a question of physics
why did bill let go of the pen
that's not a question of physics
okay
i hope the people understand the
difference between physics and
philosophy
feynman did not and he was a he got a
nobel prize
okay bill can you clarify some things
okay let's see if we can in the rope
hypothesis and i hope i understand
correctly the light rope is two threads
with electrical and magnetic properties
but those threads are immaterial
which i define as something you can
touch
you can't touch sorry if material
something you can't touch there are no
atoms or electrons or particles but you
can see and feel
for example feeling heat
well yeah the problem is he's got the
wrong definitions
he's got irrational definitions not
wrong they're wrong means it's my
opinion now he has an irrational
definition because he's saying that it's
what he can an object
matter right
matter is the set of objects that exist
he's saying uh that's what you can see
or touch
and that's where he's got the problem
uh no an object is not that which you
can see or touch because first you need
two objects to do seeing or touching you
need another object okay
and so here we put it up there so that
maybe he can learn okay
the definition of the word object
destroys all religions okay once we
define the word object all religions go
down the drain especially in
mathematical physics
an object is not that which you can see
or touch an object is that which has
shape
shape is the universal property of
objects there is no object you can
imagine that doesn't have shape
concepts don't have shape okay so uh
when he says something that you can see
or touch he's got the wrong definition
he's got the an irrational definition
uh c and touch require two objects
to make interface okay um
and you can't see or touch that table
that's on the other side of the planet
the one the chinese man is
eating his breakfast at okay
you can't see or touch it does that mean
that table is not an object because you
cannot see or touch it
how about the blind man you know he
can't see her he can't see it he can't
see the moon is the moon not an object
because the blind man can't see it
so c touched our irrational criteria for
the word object and you must define the
word object before you begin to do
physics
okay
okay so uh one fellow says uh
says i propose that all atomic in
particle forms including rope or
wave-like forms are relatively transient
manifestations of a single permanent
fundamental object okay yeah
we call it the thread okay what does he
say i describe it as a 2d
two-dimensional mobius ribbon
okay that is a seething more ass of
repelling and intransigent gazillions
lengths of that single object
my conceptualization appears to enter
some people's brains okay but then
nothing that makes sense comes out
i guess some people our brains are
opaque okay
um
the only problem i've got with uh the 2d
ribbon is that
once you twist it or you do anything
with it you got 3d
okay
you got a third dimension there
somewhere
okay
that's one issue the other one is that i
cannot imagine a 2d anything floating in
space
okay i use that uh sometimes to make fun
of god you know i say well god created
the square and he can put it there if he
wants a sheet
a two-dimensional sheet he can do it
he's all powerful he can do it but uh
mother nature analysis as powerful as
god
she cannot make squares and triangles
out there in space there are objects but
they don't exist why because they don't
have location and they don't have
location because they're 2d
and 2d would have no location here you
have to remember also that squares and
triangles and so on they're usually
subsets of 3d objects okay
in fact i think all of them are
maybe there's an exception i don't know
about but uh
all 2d uh are subsets of 3ds okay cross
sections whatever
you know what is a square it's a piece
of a cube a side of a cube what is a
circle uh it's
you know chop chop the ball in half and
you'll get a circle you know and so on
more or less like that it's a cross
section
okay uh another fella says says now
light uh rope is taught between two
atoms yeah it's pot okay
you know it's like
the tightest thing you can imagine okay
but in space there is nothing or rather
there are no material no atom okay
okay does this mean the rope can be
extremely long distance
let's say between the sun and the earth
is outer space full of electromagnetic
ropes
um
you know the
the question why don't these people ask
these questions of quantum mechanics
no one ever thought of these questions
in terms of quantum mechanics whether a
particle goes through another particle
whether two particles can be at the same
place they have no problem with it with
quantum mechanics saying that as soon as
i say
two ropes can cross each other what do
you mean two rows can cross each other i
get my ropes here at home and they don't
cross each other you know
why didn't they say that when quantum
said that two particles go through each
other why did they say that when a
two particles can occupy the same space
why did they ask the question when a
particle can be at two places at once
so the first issue is please ask those
questions first of quantum mechanics
before you ask the questions of the rope
hypothesis we need to destroy quantum
mechanics before we can replace it with
a rope right
okay but uh here it is uh let's answer
this gentleman
can there be gazillions of stars and
planets in a galaxy can you imagine that
i mean is that unimaginable
can there be gazillions of point
particles forming space time
okay
remember what is space time
uh a bunch of events what's an event a
point in space time
so you have all these gazillion points
and that's what space time is what each
point is surrounded by what encapsulates
each point well for that you got to ask
a relativist i'm not smart enough
can photons and gravitons be seen
touched i mean he's talking about seeing
and touching you know
does light travel or extend
from the andromeda galaxy to your eyes
does it travel or extend he may not know
what i'm talking about so let's
enlighten him
here it is okay here's the wave okay
you see that the wave is traveling from
the andromeda galaxy to us
or does it stretch
i mean where does the wave begin where
does it
end
that's that's the question you you need
to answer
okay
and um
and so here's the the rope model okay
and you can see that it just extends
from the andromeda galaxy to your eye
so there is no traveling through or
traveling at all what we're saying is
the rope torques in place that's why
it's so fast
okay
so the question for those who vouch for
the wave is first what is a wave but
even if we concede the wave let's just
concede it for the sake of argument does
that wave travel like a little sailboat
okay and so where does it begin where
does it end where does a wave begin
halfway
i mean it starts in an atom but
does it just fly off like a little
sailboat or is it attached to another
wave which is attached to another wave
like there
is that is it a
continuous
wave from andromeda all the way to your
eye
can it stretch that long if it's a wave
what what kind of animal is this
see under the rope it's very
straightforward the rope is a two-dimen
i'm sorry a two um
thread
two twine thread uh entity
and so you can imagine it and it just
stretches it's very thin
it's unimaginably thin and it's
unimaginably long
every piece of uh
matter in the universe is made of this
thread
there's a closed blue thread that
underlies all matter
okay so we have a consistent hypothesis
and um
and so and we're using objects so we're
doing physics on the other hand what is
a wave what is a transverse wave a bunch
of vectors that's math that's not
physics
you can't give a physical interpretation
with a famous wave but even if you can
see the wave
does it stretch
all the way from andromeda or does it
travel like a sailboat so that's the
question for
homework
we'll see on wednesday and on wednesday
we're going to have odds present we're
going to have a
live
chat live uh
answers that we're gonna try to give you
and so it's a time to embarrass us okay
so we'll see you on wednesday bye